[Applause]
you broke my streak
uh if you indulge me for a minute
because I'm just not used to this so I
had to write this down I've been lucky I
found desire for what I I do early in my
life
and I'm lucky because I had people who
encouraged that desire and uh recently a
young girl came up to me she said that I
had encouraged her
and that's not necessarily by my work
but just by the fact that uh we came
from the same place
and uh I just can't forget that girl and
I can't forget the kids out there who
may be thinking tonight
that if he can do it I can do it so uh
this is really a proud and hopeful
moment for me because
I want to thank the academy for giving
us a gift of encouragement and this is a
gift a great gift to me I thank you